collègue bonjour à toutes et à tous
merci de votre présence merci
[Musique]
notamment la mère de Plougrescant et
d'autres et puis encore plus récemment
malheureusement
monsieur Vincent j'aimerais
a été victime de d'une agression qui
n'est pas qu'une agression c'est qu'elle
ce sont des actes criminels en réalité
il faut pas la qualification pour nous
est importante c'est pas simplement
l'acte de délinquance c'est un acte
criminel qui relève en réalité la cour
d'assise faut pas perdre de vue bon donc
la situation est-elle et les agressions
que subissent les élus sont d'une telle
puisse d'une telle gravité aujourd'hui
que notre mission cherche évidemment à
avancer sur le sujet et essayer de
tenter d'apporter des réponses nous
avons pris l'initiative à quelques-uns
d'une proposition de loi qui a été
déposée il y a quelques semaines
maintenant trois semaines à peu près un
mois au Sénat dont on espère bien
qu'elle viendra assez rapidement
à la rentrée devant le Parlement
madame la Première ministre a annoncé un
grand plan dont vous avez je crois à la
charge
euh et donc l'objet de notre réunion de
ce matin c'est que vous puissiez nous
dire
quels sont les mesures qui seront mises
en oeuvre par le gouvernement et quels
sont les moyens que vous souhaitez
pouvoir développer pour assurer une
meilleure protection des élus d'une
façon générale des mères en particulier
parce que les circonstances exigent mais
des élus de façon générale j'ai presque
dire de tous ceux qui représente
l'autorité qui dans ce pays fait
actuellement l'objet de contestation de
contestation forte qui ne sont pas que
des contestations verbales et dont on
voit bien que
l'aspect de la violence physique c'est
complètement libéré
et qu'il n'y a plus de limite et que le
passage à l'acte n'est même plus une
question c'est aujourd'hui une réalité
et que de surcroît celui-ci est nature
criminelle puisqu'on a même on en est
même à revendiquer parfois la
disparition de tel ou tel élu je pense à
la mère de Pontoise il y a pas très
longtemps qui a témoigné également donc
tout ceci est évidemment inacceptable
mais notre travail nous législateur
c'est ici d'apporter une réponse voilà
je vous ai à peu près tout dit dans un
temps à peu près raisonnable avant de
vous laisser la parole naturellement
l'objectif c'est de conserver un échange
un temps d'échange avec les collègues
dans le temps qui nous est un parti
d'une heure d'une heure d'horloge merci
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs on est sur un
sujet grave qui est la menace et les
agressions subies par les élus vous
modifiez l'idée c'est effectivement que
je puisse brièvement vous dire ce que
nous avons fait ce que nous allons faire
et puis qu'on puisse échanger
de façon très directe alors en
introduction vous dire que ce phénomène
de la violence aux élus on le voit
monter depuis quelques années d'abord
dans notre quotidien de maire et puis
dans les statistiques qui montrent que
le phénomène s'accentue donc l'idée
n'est pas de sa pesantir ici sur les
causes de ces violences qui sont
nombreuses et que vous allez sans doute
identifier mais si on s'en prend aux
élus c'est parce qu'ils incarnent et
qu'il défendent de leur de public
l'autorité de l'État ils sont le premier
maillon sur lequel tout tient les
violences vise la société elle-même on
l'a vu ces derniers jours et c'est pour
ça que la lutte doit être très nous
devons faire preuve de très forte
détermination je veux dire que
contrairement à ce qu'on a parfois
entendu
l'État n'a pas abandonné les élus les
forces de sécurité sont là elles
enquêtes elles protègent les magistrats
condamnent plus durement je pense que le
garde des sceaux vous a donné quelques
éléments contrairement aux idées reçues
que dans le droit commun d'ailleurs en
revanche vous ne m'entendrez pas dire
que nous avons tout bon sur toute la
ligne ça me révèle la montrer nous avons
encore beaucoup à faire et accomplir
pour toujours et encore mieux assurer la
sécurité de nos élus c'est cette ligne
que m'a donné la première ministre elle
a une exigence c'est que tout soit mis
en oeuvre pour assurer la sécurité des
élus avec une seule boussole
évaluer protéger sanctionner et pour
évaluer je rappelle il est absolument
nécessaire de signaler c'est à dire il
faut que le les mères signal
systématiquement et non pas quand ils
considère que c'est important pourquoi
parce que ça permet une évaluation
précise derrière pour pouvoir protéger
mieux et
extanctionner ensuite ensuite nous avons
lancé le Pack Sécurité c'est le 17 mai
sur le perron 2 Matignon à la sortie de
la rencontre aux côtés de la première
ministre avec le maire de Saint-Brévin
et
et nous sommes en train de déployer ces
mesures se PACS sécurité qui pour ce que
je vois j'en suis à 81 visites de
terrain et pas moins de 10 visites en 11
jours ces deux dernières semaines
ces actions sont opérationnelles quand
on parle des 3400 gendarmes et policiers
le à l'hiver c'est à dire faire encore
plus pour être
identifié comme étant le référent
violence faite aux élus chez nos
gendarmes ces réalités les mères me le
disent même si on se connaît ils
reviennent me voir et donc nous tenons à
ce que tous les élus et véritablement
une bonne connaissance de qui est leur
interlocuteur privilégié non pas en cas
de crise mais en cas de volonté de
réflexion sur une meilleure protection
de la mairie de la personne des
bâtiments publics de leur famille et
donc ces interlocuteurs vont vraiment la
rencontre des mères alors le Pack
Sécurité c'est pas un gadget je me
souviens vous aviez
rigolé quand je vous avais
cela il y a des choses essentielles
dedans pour assurer la sécurité des élus
alors je commence par tout ce qui est
cyber violence la plateforme Pharos très
importante la plateforme Pharos elle est
entre les mains de la police nationale
mais tous les faits convergent de cyber
violence et on déferrant en déréférence
un certain nombre de plateformes et de
sites donc ça marche et n'importe quel
citoyen peut signaler une cyber violence
ensuite le pack c'était les 3400
gendarmes qui sont dans l'allé vert et
qui accompagnent la protection des élus
évidemment quand ils le souhaitent ils
sont bel et bien identifiés ils sont
formés pour passer de référents élus à
référent violence faite aux élus il y a
ce 17 aussi
fondamental moi j'étais maire et je n'ai
jamais imaginé une seconde que s'il
m'arrivait quelque chose que ce soit le
17 qu'il fallait que je compose j'avais
trois quatre numéros de portable
dans mon téléphone portable et j'avais
en plus une brigade sur ma commune bien
sûr que non que ça n'est pas les
portables des gendarmes que l'on connaît
qu'il faut appeler s'il nous appelle
quelque chose si nous arrive quelque
chose c'est le 17
et pour ce faire le rgpd oblige
évidemment le préfet le gendarme avoir
une autorisation express du maire pour
enregistrer le numéro ce n'est pas moins
depuis que je le dis de 1800 maires qui
se sont enregistrés tous mes
déplacements 20 40 mers je leur dis
donnez l'autorisation et vous serez
protéger comme il se doit ensuite ce
sentiment de sécurité parce que c'est
très important la perception par le
maire de ce sentiment de sécurité
et je perçois je voudrais rencontrer
j'ai eu au téléphone de fois j'ai
rencontré la première adjointe devenue
maire de Saint-Brévin la semaine
dernière
la perception je l'illustre par cette
nouvelle mère mais d'une façon générale
les maires ont une la perception d'être
bien protégé ensuite on a cosigné une
circulaire
[Musique]
que vous avez ici avec différents
chapitres avec le garde des sceaux
Gérald Darmanin ministre de l'Intérieur
et moi-même
cette circulaire elle vise à rappeler au
préfet et au procureur qu'il n'y a pas
de petite menace donc on ne veut plus
entendre quand un élu envisage
de porter plainte que de toute façon ça
va être classé sans suite et que et que
c'est donc pas la peine de porter
plainte donc là on est dans une demande
express de ne pas considérer qu'il y ait
des petites ou moyenne menaces on porte
plainte
on s'intéresse à toutes les menaces
ensuite on évalue systématiquement on
s'est aperçu que l'évaluation était
fondamentale pourquoi parce que il faut
pas que la protection elle donne
l'impression d'une surprotection ou
évidemment d'une sous-protection pour
cela il faut une évaluation parce que la
population peut rejeter quand elle voit
des forces de police ou de gendarmerie
très importante et qui leur apparaît à
la population lui apparaît
disproportionnée
ensuite une présence continue les
préfets les procureurs doivent assurer
une présence continue auprès des élus
menacées ou agressés il est vrai que
cette présence continue elle s'est
nourrit de la situation de Saint-Brevin
ou les attentes du maire étaient
supérieurs on prend des mesures
concrètes pour assurer la sécurité des
mères le ministre de l'Intérieur demandé
au préfet de prendre toutes les mesures
nécessaires pour assurer la sécurité des
élus qui en ont besoin ce sont tous nos
policiers et gendarmes qui sont donc
mobilisés ce train de mesure ne laisse
pas de côté au contraire le point
essentiel de la réponse judiciaire
particulièrement actuellement dans le
garde des soins déjà eu l'occasion de
vous parler tout d'abord nous sommes
montrés ouverts à adopter des
dispositions proposées par le sénateur
de braise qui renforce les sanctions
pénales applicables
ça c'est clair ça n'a pas pu passer dans
la locmi il nous faut trouver le moment
pour faire passer ce texte
la circulaire que je viens de mentionner
demande au parquet de créer des filières
d'urgence
des sortes de coupe-files pour faire en
sorte que les affaires de violence faite
aux élus soit traitées plus rapidement
et troisièmement nous sommes aussi
ouverts à travailler à compléter le code
pénal pour que nous soyons certains
d'avoir tous les outils répressifs
utiles pour bien traiter les auteurs des
violences faites aux élus
alors nous sommes conscients ça c'est un
petit peu le 17 mai la circulaire les
annonces mais nous sommes conscients que
nous devons aller plus loin donc dès le
lendemain du 17 mai la première ministre
nous a demandé de travailler à un plan
national de prévention et de lutte
contre les violences aux élus qui est
aujourd'hui quasi finalisé
ce plan tente de rassembler toutes les
propositions qui ont été faites par les
associations d'élus mais aussi par vous
le Sénat par l'Assemblée nationale il
recoud passer largement par ailleurs les
propositions que vous avez faites dans
l'importante PPL déposer fin mai au
Sénat par vous même monsieur le
Président ce plan cherche à agir sur
quatre axes le premier la protection
juridique et psychologique
le deuxième la sécurité physique des
élus le troisième la réponse judiciaire
le quatrième les relations entre les
mères et les parquets
je veux dire que ces d'ores et déjà
réalité je vous disais que j'étais à 81
visite de terrain je peux dire que dans
les 70 premières les procureurs ne sont
jamais venus à mes rencontres avec les
mers
toutes mes dernières rencontres avec les
mères à l'initiative de la MF ou
quiconque ou du préfet j'ai toujours vu
les procureurs procureurs sont présents
dans ces rencontres avec les mères et
même si c'est le fruit de la circulaire
que l'on a envoyé il y a quelques temps
en fait le message est bien passé
l'objet n'est pas de rentrer ici dans le
détail du plan je pourrais revenir si
vous le souhaitez si simplement quelques
exemples de ce que nous avons cherché à
faire nous allons renforcer la
protection fonctionnelle on la rendant
automatique et les tendons et en
renforçant sa prise en charge
donc jusque comme vous l'aviez souhaité
jusqu'au commune de 10 000 habitants
ce plan à partir de vos réflexions et de
vos travaux
merci Madame la Ministre alors qui
souhaite s'exprimer il y a-t-il des
questions monsieur Lamarque
madame Gatel
et Monsieur Henri Leroy
merci monsieur le Président alors
Monsieur Lamarck merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre
nous disions l'autre jour lorsque nous
avons reçu le directeur général de la
gendarmerie nationale
que Nelly chez moi a porté 5 fois
plainte
avant d'être avant que c'est le ciste
dernière ne soit prise en compte par par
le parquet alors sans doute la
l'actualité y était le pour quelque
chose mais
je pense que et je le disais que dans la
formation aussi peut-être des procureurs
et dans l'exercice de leur fonction tous
les jours il est absolument nécessaire
et vous l'avez dit désormais lorsque
vous vous rendez à la demande d'une ADN
dans un département les procureurs les
procureurs sont présents mais traiter ce
problème c'est très bien le traite en
aval moi il me semble que de façon plus
globale il faut peut-être repenser la
place du maire dans la société et se
poser à nouveau la question du statut de
l'élu parce qu'il s'agit aussi de cela
là on traite bien évidemment d'un
problème qui aujourd'hui est prégnant
parce que dans la société il y a des
incidents avec beaucoup de avec beaucoup
de démissionne d'élus ce qui pour nous
nous interroge puisqu'en 2026 il y aura
à nouveau des élections municipales mais
il faut je pense travailler de nouveau
sans doute par un projet de loi le
statut de l'élu est singulièrement celui
du maire dans la société avec les
possibilités
pour ces derniers exercer leur leur
fonction dans toute les dimensions que
l'on souhaite et possible puisque
aujourd'hui ils sont à la fois dans les
petites communes juge de paix ils
décident de projet etc etc là on ne
traite que l'aval il y a des problèmes
avec certains administrés et bien je
crois qu'il faut vraiment revenir à ce
statut là
merci monsieur le Président merci Madame
la mini je pense qu'il nous faut
dissocier cette situation de crise qui
nous amène et on ne peut que vous en
remercier à proposer des plans et la
situation que j'ose appeler un peu de
temps calme et qui est une situation
récurrente où le lien entre
l'élu et le citoyen se distend de plus
en plus et que je pense qu'il faut
travailler sur des réponses de long
terme sur l'éducation un changement de
culture entre tous les acteurs y compris
vous l'avez dit la justice et les élus
faut prévenir protéger sanctionner donc
moi je voudrais reprendre quelques
éléments extrêmement simples
l'évaluation est extrêmement importante
parce que je pense qu'on a tendance par
des temps de surchauffe à surréagir ou à
afficher pardonnez-moi le mot est
maladroit mais vous comprenez ce que je
veux dire à sortir des choses qui
seraient très fortes très puissante mais
à un moment
les uns et les autres vont un peu
s'endormir ça a passé l'actualité et on
retrouvera des phénomènes d'exaspération
de cette nature donc nous avons été très
frappés par la situation de Saint-Brevin
où on a vu avec le respect du à chacun
une sorte de dysfonctionnements ou en
tout cas de mal fonctionnement qui fait
que tout au long de la chaîne depuis le
début de cette affaire de cada jusqu'à
la fin il y a eu une sorte
d'indifférence au sens de non prise de
conscience de risque et d'évaluation des
risques quand on est dans une société ou
dans une république on inscrit dans la
Constitution le principe de précaution
c'est quand même à mon donc je pense
qu'il faut vraiment retirer de cette
situation des enseignements travailler
sur la formation des magistrats et la
formation sans doute des policiers et
des
et des gendarmes et je distinguerai
peut-être où je prévaloir une différence
entre les gendarmes les zones
gendarmerie et les zones police de
manière générale dans les zones de
gendarmerie les gendarmes vivent au
milieu de la population leurs enfants
vont à l'école ils participent au club
de foot vous avez une relation parfois
plus je sais pas dire naturel mais vous
voyez le policier il est le gendarme il
est dans la vie de tous les jours et que
je pense que il y a là à un moment
sans doute
à risque peut-être de moindre dérapage
que dans les zones de comment c'est la
censure merci Monsieur Canet il y a sans
doute un risque de dérapage et puis je
pense madame la mini vous dites qu'il y
a une circulaire moi je suis ravie mais
il y a des lois des lois de 2019
engagement et proximité et des lois 3DS
inscrits dans la loi l'obligation d'une
relation et d'une action efficace très
bien définie entre le procureur et le
maire et nous avons eu l'occasion à la
délégation
d'auditionner monsieur le garde des
sceaux qui nous a expliqué qu'il y a des
endroits où ça fonctionnait plutôt très
bien et d'autres parce que les
procureurs sont pris peut-être pas autre
chose de leur sensibilité moins ça ne
fonctionne pas et je pense que il faut
qu'on soit dans cette approche
systématique qui fait qu'on fait une
sorte de rempart de sécurité de filets
de sécurité autour des élus je vous
remercie
la Présidente Monsieur Henri Leroy puis
monsieur Kanner président canner
le nombre de violences verbales et
physique contre les élus et passer de
1720 à
2265 en 2022 selon les chiffres du
ministre de l'Intérieur dévoilaient le
15 mars il y a quelques semaines vous
annonciez la création d'une cellule
d'analyse et de lutte spécifiquement
dédiée à la lutte contre les atteintes
aux élus et les mesures législatives
visant à renforcer les sanctions
devraient être présenté avant l'été les
agressions envers les élus locaux se
multiplient avec un pic de violence
inouïe ces derniers jours dus aux
émeutes bien sûr depuis des mois vous
multipliez les rencontres avec les élus
avec des résultats encore peu visibles
quelle mesure concrètes le gouvernement
envisage-t-il de prendre rapidement pour
garantir la sécurité des élus locaux et
prévenir les menaces et agressions qu'il
subissent merci merci Monsieur Leroy
monsieur prenant canner
madame la ministre ne prenait pas ce que
je vais vous dire pour vous même
et pour ce que vous représentez
seul le président Kanner à la parole
mais c'était pour justement vous êtes
des préliminaires étant passé allons-y
c'est le Président Madame ministre ça
fait 75 mois que vous êtes au pouvoir
la situation n'a jamais été aussi
difficile pour les îles locaux et vous
portez une part de responsabilité
évidente vous avez affaibli quand je dis
vous c'est à VOUS collectif
naturellement vous avez affaibli
l'autonomie financière et fiscale des
collectivités locales vous avez liquider
les emplois aidés au secteur associatif
vous avez diminué les moyens de
l'éducation populaire vous nous avez
supprimé de fait les clubs de prévention
spécialisés et on s'étonne aujourd'hui
et moi je suis en colère madame la
ministre j'ai 20 villes dans le Nord 20
villes dans le Nord qui ont été
massacrés
massacré la ville de Denain son centre
ville n'existe plus
des centaines de millions de d'euros de
travaux j'ai écouté ce matin Olivia
Grégoire sur le plan d'urgence etc mais
vous êtes toujours un temps en retard et
vous êtes quelque part un arroseur
arrosé et voilà de d'agression d'élus
agressions d'élus de violences
urbaine à violence urbaine et bien vous
courrez toujours derrière l'événement
mais finalement vous l'avez provoqué par
une politique qui est considérée comme
un juste par et je m'excuse rien du tout
vous l'avez bien compris enfin vous
savez que quel est notre position en la
matière les violences sont inexcusables
il ne s'agit pas de les comprendre il
s'agit de les condamner mais néanmoins
notre place nous devons regarder votre
bilan 75 mois 64 mois j'ai été ministre
de la ville on le dit souvent voir qu'il
devrait se pourrait dire la même chose
je n'ai jamais connu une telle situation
alors que nous étiez en pleine période
d'attentat et pas des moindres et pas
des moindres donc Madame le Ministre moi
je vraiment je vous interpelle vous
pouvez pas excusez-moi balader la la
sensation nationale de petits textes en
petit texte surtout en ayant coupé la
branche de l'autonomie globale politique
des des maires dans dans ce pays donc je
suis en colère parce que j'ai vu des
maires dans les larmes le maire de
mons-en-barœul qui a vu sa mairie 25000
habitants qui a vu sa mairie brûlée
alors que il porte une politique de
d'aménagement urbain extraordinaire sur
l'enrue sur les politiques sociales
voilà on lui a brûlé sa mairie vous
allez me dire je ne suis pas responsable
nous sommes tous responsables mais vous
êtes aux responsabilités centrale donc
je voulais vous le dire
il y a un moment donné il faut que vous
entendiez cette colère profonde les mers
ne peuvent pas être les variables
d'ajustement de l'incurie politique de
ce gouvernement
merci Monsieur kaner Monsieur Eric héros
je suis Monsieur Richard et Monsieur
Darnaud
bien bonjour j'allais dire Patrick Kader
a dit l'essentiel
comment dire
et puis j'allais dire que après balance
ton maire on va pas faire balance ton
ministre ça serait assez mal venu
néanmoins
quelques quelques réflexions le
[Musique]
ce qui s'est passé je pense à
traumatiser une grande partie du pays et
rien n'est rien n'est excusable dans les
débordements qui sont plus que des qui
sont plus que des débordements parce
qu'ils remettrent en péril l'ensemble du
pacte républicain avec des conséquences
qui peuvent être on le sait très grave
et qui le sont qui le sont déjà
le recul n'est pas recul effectivement
ponctuel ça recule systémique c'est un
recul dans le temps
en 2018 j'avais commis un petit ouvrage
qui s'appelait le blues des mers et qui
traitait de l'ensemble de ces de
l'ensemble de ces sujets et dans ces
sujets on voyait déjà la difficulté des
mères à assumer une partie de leur de
leurs fonctions mettant l'accent
d'ailleurs sur le fait que disposant de
moins de moyens et singulièrement le
volant des emplois et des était un
élément essentiel de fonctionnement du
local et bien quand on enlève une partie
des moyens le système ne peut plus se
stabiliser je parle des la capacité des
élus à faire
et il est assez révélateur que on parle
sans cesse de de statut de statut de
l'élu mais en fait
il y avait une loi qui était censée
promouvoir ce statut de l'élu c'était
engagement et proximité et il s'avère
que engagement et proximité n'a touché
le statut calamarge alors prenons-en
notre part il y a aussi une crainte de
la part des parlementaires que nous
sommes de légiférer en faveur des élus
parce que justement nous craignons à
tort ou à raison et je pense à tort la
réaction des citoyens mais redéfinir le
statut de l'élu c'est aussi le rôle de
ceux qui sont responsabilités n'ont pas
simplement en le disant en le proposant
mais en le faisant ce qui n'a pas été
fait depuis des années or si on veut
redonner de la confiance si on veut
démocratiser l'accès il faut transformer
le statut de l'élu de manière radicale
j'ai lu une partie de vos réponses en la
matière dans la presse elles ne sont à
mon sens pas la hauteur de la
transformation qu'il faudrait faire avec
mes collègues du groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicains nous venons
de déposer une PPL sur le statut d'élus
qui change radicalement la façon
d'aborder la façon d'aborder celui-ci et
où on repousse toujours les solutions et
nous serons toujours des spectateurs et
ce nous sommes des spectateurs on sera
sans cesse on sera sans cesse condamné
pour ne pas avoir su anticiper ce qui
est en train de se passer et c'est tout
ce qu'on vous demande madame la ministre
c'est simplement de répondre à une crise
qui est profonde
un certain nombre ici dans cette salle
sont renouvelables
bien entendu à l'envoi beaucoup d'élus
dans leur dans leur département et moi
je vous le dis très
clairement ce qui me ce qui m'interroge
c'est le changement de tonalité entre
la période que nous vivons et la période
il y a 6 ans les interrogations des élus
sont beaucoup plus fortes leur doute le
son tout autant et leur crainte sont
tout à fait effectivement
un moment donné encore une fois on ne
peut pas être que spectateur et donc ma
question est toute simple quand quand il
y aura-t-il vraiment un texte de loi qui
met au niveau le statut des élus pas
pour en faire une caste à part mais pour
respecter simplement l'organisation de
la République et faire en sorte que
celle-ci perdure
merci Monsieur Caroche il y a encore
quatre collègues qui veulent intervenir
peut-être
en faire assez court et après madame la
ministre répondra mais on s'arrêtera la
liste là parce que dans un premier temps
monsieur Richard monsieur d'Arnaud
monsieur Marie Monsieur Bonhomme
c'est bien Madame la Ministre moi je
voudrais vous je vais vous parler de
moi je voudrais vous parler de la
prévention des conflits c'est les ceux
qui ont été maires dans cette salle
savent que il y a de toute façon
toujours
des rencontres avec des concitoyens qui
peuvent se passer mal pour 36000 raisons
liées au quotidien de
vivre ensemble voilà
le maire qui qui reçoit un concitoyen
qui se plaint de l'aboiement des chiens
autour et que si ce concitoyen n'a pas
eu satisfaction la première ou la
deuxième fois la troisième fois il
s'énerve etc donc ça ça existe ça
existera toujours on arrivera
naturellement pas à empêcher ces
discours enflammés voire pour certains
de ces incidents des agressions voilà
moi je voudrais vous parler de la
prévention des conflits qui montent sur
un certain nombre de thématiques que je
vais pas citer ici mais que l'on
pourrait éviter exemple
nul doute que que si on améliore pas la
situation en ce qui concerne le zan
prenons par exemple zan et à l'heure
actuelle je sais pas vers où on va au
niveau de l'Assemblée nationale mais si
on améliore pas la situation c'est sûr
que les maires vont à nouveau être en
première ligne face au mécontentement
des gens qui diront mais moi je veux
construire etc etc je peux pas vous avez
rien compris votre plus c'est la mentale
enfin nul doute que ça va venir donc moi
j'appelle à ce que il y est une prise en
compte on a voté un texte qui nous
paraît
plutôt convenir il faudrait pas que ça
chope et qu'on se retrouve de nouveau
face à un texte dur et autre exemple ici
au Sénat on a voté une proposition de
loi sur
les gens du voyage l'accueil des gens du
voyage
ce texte est enquisté à l'Assemblée
nationale mais mais c'est sûr que si ça
continue comme ça ça va continuer le
maire va en prendre plein la tête
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire il va aller
voir les nettoyage ils vont lui dire non
vous pouvez pas rester là etc etc il
aura pas les moyens il va s'en prendre
plein la tête on va vers des agressions
moi ce que je voudrais et je vais très
court ce que j'aimerais bien c'est que
le gouvernement examine toutes les
situations je parle pas du quotidien les
aboiements de chien les voisins ni nana
mais toutes les situations structurelles
qui à l'heure actuelle sont susceptibles
et vont occasionner si vous le voulez
moi je suis persuadé moi je vais le
faire moi-même si vous le voulez mais je
suis sûr qu'ici la délégation présidée
par Françoise Gatel est capable de de
dresser un certain nombre de situations
qui sont structurellement irritantes
pour des concitoyens vis-à-vis de
vis-à-vis des maires et qui sont
récurrentes on doit pouvoir
effectivement intervenir dans la
prévention de ces conflits pour éviter
que la situation s'envenime dans un
certain nombre de situations je vous
remercie merci Monsieur Richard monsieur
Darnaud oui merci monsieur le Président
je vais essayer d'être le plus
pragmatique possible et poser notamment
deux questions
malheureusement on a le sentiment que
les événements se succèdent les uns aux
autres et quand je parle d'événements
pas nécessairement ceux que nous venons
de connaître aussi douloureux soit-il
mais
nombreuses sont les situations qui
mettent les maires en première ligne que
ce soit lors de conflits sociaux que ce
soit et on l'a vu avec Saint-Brevin et
tant d'autres mers qui ont dû faire face
à la situation de violence et que à
chaque fois la situation se répète où on
sort à la hâte
un projet de loi où on sort un texte des
mesures très ponctuelles
d'accompagnement nous aimerions enfin
que le gouvernement et encore une fois
le Parlement prendra toute sa place
d'ailleurs nous avons et nous allons
encore formuler madame la ministre
d'ailleurs je regrette que la ministre
des collectivités n'est pas pu répondre
à la mission d'information sur l'avenir
des maires et de la commune nous avons
invité depuis plus d'un mois et demi
nous allons rendre le rapport et
finalement il n'y a que la ministre qui
n'aura pas répondu à notre invitation
c'est assez regrettable je le dis parce
que c'est un sujet sur lequel nous avons
essayé de faire ovutile et d'être très
pragmatique sur les propositions que
nous allons formuler première chose il y
a des choses qui marchent et qui
fonctionnent et malheureusement on ne
les voit pas être dupliqués un exemple
nous étions l'autre jour dans la Somme
nous avons rencontré le procureur de la
République qui a mis un moyen
spécialement dédié pour suivre la boîte
mail dans la sur laquelle les élus
peuvent faire part des violences
auxquelles ils sont confrontés et on
voit tout de suite la réactivité mais
quand ça marche pardon de le dire ça
n'est jamais reproduit jamais dupliquer
on va toujours chercher ce qui ne
fonctionne pas première chose la
deuxième madame la ministre ça fait deux
fois que j'ai eu à la tribune notamment
plateau l'occasion de vous poser la
question je pense que phase à cette
crise que traverse les mers et au manque
d'agilité et vous même l'avez rappelé il
y a un sujet qui s'appelle le pouvoir
réglementaire local et à deux reprises
je vous ai posé la question sans
qu'aucune fois vous n'ayez donné un
exemple de pouvoir réglementaire local
qui aujourd'hui se décline et s'applique
sur les territoires à l'instar de ce que
nous souhaitions avec Françoise Gatel
introduire dans le texte 3DS donc si
vous pouviez ce matin me donner un seul
exemple j'en monte pas deux trois un
seul exemple de pouvoir réglementaire
local qui se décline et que peuvent
actionner les mers sur les territoires
je vous en remercie par avance si
Monsieur Darnaud Monsieur Didier Marie
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre vous n'êtes pas ministre de
l'Intérieur vous n'êtes pas ministre de
la politique de la ville mais vous
représentez ici le gouvernement donc je
me permettrai de revenir sur deux trois
points liés à la situation que nous
venons de connaître
et je vais m'appuyer sur ce qui s'est
passé dans mon territoire la métropole
de Rouen et plus particulièrement la
ville d'Elbeuf
cela fait des mois et des mois que la
majorité des élus de ce territoire les
71 mers réclament des moyens
supplémentaires en matière de police
quelques moyens supplémentaires ont été
attribués mais ils n'ont pas compensé
les départs en retraite et les mutations
résultat pendant les émeutes l'essentiel
des moyens a été concentré sur la ville
centre Rouen ce qui était tout à fait
compréhensible mais pendant deux nuits
la ville d'Elbeuf a été livrée au
pilleur les forces de police présente
n'étant là que pour protéger
commissariat et n'étant pas en capacité
de protéger le reste du territoire
c'est un premier sujet on nous parle
beaucoup de l'augmentation des effectifs
de la police nationale mais la réalité
c'est qu'ils ne sont pas suffisamment
présents encore sur le terrain deuxième
sujet
nous avons connu ces dernières années
une diminution des crédits de la
politique de la ville en particulier au
bénéfice des associations ça a été dit
tout à l'heure nous avons vu aussi la
suppression des employés la suppression
de toute une série d'emplois aidés et
ces emplois là étaient majoritairement
destinés aux jeunes des quartiers était
un moyen d'amener un certain nombre
d'entre eux à s'insérer tout en
permettant aussi de lier du bien social
sur le territoire vous nous direz les
crédits de la rue ont augmenté oui
certes sauf que le nombre de réussite a
aussi augmenté résultat on a dilué et
les
délais d'instruction des dossiers sont
tels que tout ça traîne et n'apporte pas
les responses les réponses
que nous attendons et je voudrais à cet
égard rappeler l'abandon du plan Borlo
dont on repart aujourd'hui suite à ces
émeutes moi je me souviens de la manière
dont Monsieur borlou a été appelé par le
Président de la République ce grand mal
blanc qui n'avait pas compris ce qu'il
devait être fait dans les quartiers que
de temps de perdu que de gâchis et
j'espère que ce qui vient de se passer
permettra aux présidents de la
République et au gouvernement de
remettre ce chantier sur la table enfin
dernière élément à qui profite tout ça
c'est notre pacte républicain qui est en
danger regardez les études d'opinion qui
sortent depuis quelques jours le champ
républicain est balayé et les
conséquences politiques de tout ça sont
dramatique et ce n'est pas simplement en
accueillant 220 mères à l'Élysée et en
leur promettant une augmentation de
leurs indemnités que l'on va régler la
situation et j'en viens à ce que disait
Eric et rouge à l'instant les mères
aujourd'hui sont en première ligne ils
sont en difficulté ils attendent du
gouvernement plus qu'une augmentation de
la maternité il demande de la
reconnaissance et face à la
responsabilité qu'il a l'heure à la
complexification de leur mission
sachant que plus de la moitié d'entre
eux considèrent qu'il ne passe plus de
35 heures à l'exercice de leur mandat et
un tiers des adjoints de même c'est d'un
nouveau paradigme qu'il faut parler
aujourd'hui qui est celui de la
professionnalisation de la fonction
pendant la période du mandat
merci Monsieur la dernière intervenant
Monsieur François bonhomme madame la
ministre répondra ensuite
merci monsieur le Président et moi je
voudrais simplement dire
les mères forcément en quelques années
se retrouvent et les adjoints et les
élus municipaux sont la seule catégorie
de Lyon on peut le dire ici qui sont le
véritablement exposés en permanence
alors population et pour cause puisque
leur situation de proximité d'immersion
les exposent en tout un tas de choses et
ils se font souvent les porteurs de
mauvaises nouvelles de règles qui sont
obligées d'imposer et de faire respecter
on a parlé des situations de médiation
entre des relations
interpersonnelles qui sont de plus en
plus compliquées mais en matière
d'urbanisme on voit bien à chaque fois
combien ça peut être un facteur de
tension et le zanne sans doute va encore
aggraver les choses de ce point de vue
moi je ne ferai pas l'intervention sur
il n'y a qu'à et c'est parce que
la situation le sait la réponse est
multifactorielle ainsi que les causes
simplement la partie judiciaire la
réponse judiciaire me semble quand même
tout à fait importante du point de vue
que l'État doit indiquer aussi à à la
société en général combien la figure du
maire et des élus en partie notamment
sont une figure qui intouchable et que
il s'expose à les sanctions tout à fait
rapide forte et
importante dans le cas contraire
je ne crois pas aux explications
sociales j'ai entendu dire qu'ici
ça serait le défaut d'investissement
public qui serait une des causes
importantes je crois qu'on a
non pas déversé mais en tout cas engagés
de dépenses considérables à différents
types de politiques de la ville et que
les dégradations de bien public parfois
tout neufs ne viennent pas de là bien au
contraire la partie éducative bien sûr
est interrogée et je ne crois pas que
les biotechs qui ont été attaqués
c'était parce qu'il y avait une espèce
de désir ardent de lecture qui a
expliqué les choses je ne vois pas le
lien là-dessus et
bientôt des engagement de l'État
monsieur canard parlait de
l'affaiblissement de l'autonomie fiscale
c'est vrai que je suis de ceux qui n'ont
pas
souhaité l'exonération de la taxe
d'habitation parce que le lien civique
de ce point de vue a été coupé en
revanche je rappelle quand même que les
collectivités n'ont jamais autant été
impactés lorsqu'elles ont subi ce qu'on
appelait à l'époque publiquement le plan
de réduction de contribution de
réduction en dette publique des
collectivités locales qui en fait
c'était traduit par 11 milliards d'euros
d'au moins pour la DGF donc du point de
vue du point de vue de de du coup quand
même très mortel pour l'équipement un
service public local là je pense qu'on
n'a pas fait mieux depuis donc il faut
être prudent dans ce propos là voilà
mais après madame la ministre ça
n'empêche que à pas se propose veillez
non plus à ne pas faire trop de
communication quand vous appelez le Pack
Sécurité moi j'ai l'impression d'être
chez un opérateur téléphonique et je
pense que
et je pense qu'il voudrait mieux si haut
de Morat après les points de Lopez je
pense que le 90% ici souscrivent mais
c'est vraiment des petits pas et on
continuum créer un écosystème de
sécurité du maire qui doit être fait à
travers la police justice notamment mais
la partie éducative est beaucoup plus
compliquée et demande du long terme
voilà mais je veux dire merci
on a besoin aussi d'avancer ce domaine
merci Monsieur Madame
on parle des maires aujourd'hui et des
violences qu'il subissent j'étais votre
attention sur ce qui s'est passé à
l'audience et judiciaire hier à Lyon
ou le tribunal le à l'audience qui de
ont été jugés les personnes qui ont
commis des actes de délinquance voir des
actes criminels l'audience a été
perturbé par des gens qui sont du
manifester contre la police avec des
propos qui sont invraisemblables donc
c'est à dire que c'est du meilleur
général l'autorité qui est contestée
même la ministre avait la parole
à quel point le président de la
République la première ministre et tout
le gouvernement souscrivant à ce que
vous venez de dire monsieur le Président
tout simplement l'autorité est
constestée partout et s'il y a bien un
enseignement que l'on tire et une
réflexion que l'on conduit c'est bien
autour de cette autorité de ce respect
de l'autre que nous devons travailler
tous ensemble alors bon je vais essayer
de répondre
j'ai un petit quart d'heure à tous les
sénateurs le sénateur marque
vous avez élargi
le sujet qui nous préoccupe aujourd'hui
et vous êtes allés sur le terrain du
statut de l'élu alors comme beaucoup
d'entre vous si le président kaner même
si je réponds pas à sa question mais
écoutez ça serait super gentil non mais
je vous en veux pas simplement comme je
réponds à une partie des questions que
vous m'avez posées
mais c'est pas grave simplement le
statut de vous dire qu'il y a maintenant
deux mois quasi de moi j'ai fait une
grosse séance de travail avec David
Lisnard et l'AMF pour
lui dire que je voulais travailler le
sujet des conditions d'exercice du
mandat d'élus local
et que avec ma petite expérience de ces
derniers mois et la violence telle
qu'elle est aujourd'hui dont je vous
dirai quelques mots je voulais décorer
les sujets violences faites aux élus
c'est ce dont nous parlons aujourd'hui
et
c'est ce plan national de prévention
encore une fois celui du 17 mai était
pas parfait celui-là on va la demander
de tout ce que vous allez vous nous avez
dit il sera pas parfait on va la
demander on va y travailler ensemble
mais en tout cas c'est un sujet sur
lequel effectivement la première
ministre m'a mandatée la corrélation
entre les deux elle est pas évidente moi
je dis que c'est autour de 15% des
démissions d'élus qui prennent leur
source et leurs origines dans la
violence faite aux élus seulement donc
c'est une des causes pour lesquelles nos
élus démissionnent en tout cas je
voulais vous dire que le sujet du statut
de l'élu je le prends à bras le corps et
j'ai été extrêmement heureuse et
j'entends comme vous l'avez dit que ça
fait 40 ans ça tourne que l'on entend
parler 30 ans 20 ans on a cru dans des
lois qui ont été votées sur le fait que
le statut de l'élu serait véritablement
au cœur de notre travaux j'espère tout
simplement parce que j'ai sollicité le
président de la MF parce que je
considérais que c'était et pourtant j'ai
très bonne relation avec la RF aussi
toutes les associations d'élus mais
qu'on pouvait travailler utilement à
deux et dès qu'on va dire le mois de
juillet on va avoir une liste
aujourd'hui on est à 80 irritants 80
sujets 80 problèmes que rencontrent nos
élus l'idée c'est de l'inventorier de
façon exhaustive pour pouvoir en face y
mettre les solutions certaines seront
d'ordre réglementaires d'autres
législatives qu'est-ce qu'on va trouver
dans ces conditions d'exercices du
mandat d'élus il y a évidemment le
statut de l'élu le statut de l'élu c'est
trois composantes c'est tout ce qui
touche à l'indemnisation c'est tout ce
qui touche au remboursement de frais
c'est tout ce qui touche deuxièmement à
ses droits sociaux
c'est tous et troisièmement c'est la
formation le droit à la formation des
élus aujourd'hui on a des bouts de code
un peu partout sur le statut de l'élu on
n'a pas véritablement une approche comme
on l'a pour le statut de la fonction
publique territoriale on n'a pas le
statut de l'élu et ça le mérite donc
vous avez la online et en réponse à
votre question un travail que l'on a
initié la première chose que l'on va
faire dès que l'on aura inventorier les
causes et trouver déjà quelques ébauches
de solutions c'est évidemment d'élargir
tout de suite au Sénat
d'élargir à l'Assemblée nationale
d'élargir aux autres associations des
lieux on va faire un colloque ensemble
au mois de septembre où on va essayer de
s'assurer qu'on a rien oublié dans tous
les problèmes que rencontre nos mères et
on va co-construire les solutions
ensemble pour aboutir au Congrès des
mers avec ce que j'espère
un statut de l'élu donc vous avez au
gouvernement quelqu'un que je suis qui
milite pour que enfin on a bouche sur ce
sujet on débouche sur ce sujet dont tout
le monde parle mais finalement on a de
si de la amélioré la situation mais je
pense que cette crise récente la et ses
émeutes elle doivent normalement
nos invités tout ça à conclure avant la
fin de l'année sur un statut de l'élu
donc vous avez évoqué le fait de
repenser la place du maire dans la
société là ça touche à tous ces sujets
éducatifs que beaucoup de vous avaient
mais je souscris à tout ce que vous avez
dit mais la question principale est
tournée autour du statut de l'élu je
pense vous y avoir répondu
la sénatrice Gatel
vous avez
renforcé le fait que l'évaluation elle
devait être
précise juste et éviter toute forme de
surréaction et
vous avez indiqué
que cette évaluation elle était
absolument nécessaire donc vous dire que
on a une doctrine que l'on n'avait pas
aussi clairement formulé jusqu'à
maintenant pour aider
nos préfets tout simplement à évaluer à
se poser les bonnes questions et pour
que ces évaluations soient les plus
pertinentes possibles pour que la
protection soit la plus pertinente
possible donc
je voulais dit de façon un peu
informelle en vous disant ce que je
vivais depuis 15 jours 3 semaines avec
cette présence des procureurs à toutes
les âgées des mets c'est écrit dans la
circulaire ça leur est demandé donc moi
je souscris ce qu'a dit monsieur le
garde des sceaux il y a des endroits
dans lequel ça fonctionne bien des
endroits dans lesquels ça fonctionne
moins bien vous évoquez le fait que en
zone gendarmerie il y a
une prise en compte
[Musique]
de ce sentiment de sécurité beaucoup
plus forte parce que les gendarmes
vivent sur le territoire c'est juste une
évidence je suis pas fondé moi à vous
dire à quel si oui ou non la police on
pourrait travailler pour que
effectivement il réside sur leur
territoire comme les gendarmes mais en
tout cas je souscris en tant que mère
ayant été en zone gendarmerie que cet
extrême proximité est plus utile
ensuite le sénateur le roi
alors vous avez évoqué les chiffres
sénateurs le roi vous voyez vous avez
évoqué les chiffres
2021-2022
des chiffres y compris les 12 parce que
vous m'avez entendu dire 6 atteintes à
des élus pendant les émeutes en fait on
est à 12 parce que des atteintes même
mineur on les considère comme des
atteintes c'est des chiffres consolidés
entre gendarmerie et
AMF donc remonter
mais ces chiffres ils ont baissé au
premier semestre 2023 donc de 4% pour
les atteintes aux mères donc voilà
est-ce un signal sur le fait que le
nombre baisse mais en tout cas la
gravité on le voit là extrêmement
[Musique]
forte dans les mesures que l'on que l'on
prend sur le nombre de patrouilles qui
ont été grandement
augmenté sur le plan de la surveillance
sur la plante de la mise en place de
caméras toutes les gendarmerie sont
maintenant équipées de caméras qu'ils
peuvent poser évidemment à la demande du
procureur pour immédiatement observer
les allées venus devant les domiciles
devant les mairies tout cela est en
ordre de marche donc quand vous appelez
de vos vœux tous et vraiment je souscris
des mesures concrètes encore une fois
tout peut être complété mais en tout cas
elles sont là
ces mesures concrètes aujourd'hui
[Musique]
vous voulez qu'on évalue l'efficacité
pour l'instant on est beaucoup trop tôt
par rapport à ce que l'on a annoncé le
17 mai par rapport à ce que l'on va
annoncer maintenant moi j'évalue au gré
de mes rencontres ce que me disent les
mères voilà j'évalue que globalement se
Pack Sécurité monsieur le sénateur dont
je souscris sur le fait qu'il y avait
pas besoin de le marketer et de lui
donner un nom il pouvait s'appeler tout
à fait autrement mais en tout cas ces
mesures
elles sont perçues par les mers comme
étant utiles et encore une fois avec
beaucoup d'humilité sur le fait qu'on
peut toujours en prendre des
complémentaires
alors monsieur le Président kaner
je vais tout simplement
pas partager votre point de vue mais
c'est tout le plaisir de pouvoir
débattre entre républicains démocrate et
de pouvoir dire à quel point je ne
partage pas votre point de vue je
partage pas votre point de vue déjà je
le partageais pas avant d'avoir écouté
je pense environ 150 mers sur les 400
qui ont été reçus à l'Élysée hier mais
c'était comme une évidence à la sortie
de d'avoir écouté ces 400 mères sur le
fait que il est urgent de ne tirer aucun
enseignement de ce qui s'est passé
ces six derniers jours à court terme
pourquoi bien sûr que non et on continue
surtout pas pourquoi on on
je pense qu'il est urgent de ne pas
tirer d'enseignement d'abord parce que
sur les 120 mers qui se sont qui se sont
exprimés il y en a 60 qui ont tenu vos
propos et 60 cantonnent des propos
orthogonaux
déjà donc il y a pas du tout un
consensus sur le fait que il faille
réinventer une nouvelle politique de la
ville où il faille absolument remettre
de l'argent dans la politique de la
ville non il n'y a pas consensus
là-dessus et je voudrais prendre pour
exemple quasi l'unanimité des
associations d'élus que nous avons
reçues autour de la première ministre la
semaine dernière tous on dit que ce
n'était que des gros pluscules dans ces
quartiers de politique de la ville qui
avait fait flamber nos mairie qui avait
payé les magasins je quitte la vie de
Toulouse parce que je le suis de près
parce que je suis une ancienne élue de
ce territoire mais sur les quatre
quartiers de politique de la ville c'est
pas plus de 80
individus qui ont et d'ailleurs on voit
à quel point ça a baissé c'est-à-dire
que au début il y a une prise on a été
pris par surprise et
ensuite très vite ça a été jugulé
particulièrement à Toulouse parce que
justement on a compris comment il
procédé le deuxième jour ça a été un peu
mieux le troisième un peu mieux mais on
a été pris par surprise parce qu'ils
attaquaient partout et avec des formes
auxquelles on n'était pas habitués mais
sérieusement beaucoup de mères ont dit
hier pas moins de trois que j'avais
autour de moi avec qui je parlais en
aparté
à quel point ils se sont appuyés sur les
habitants des quartiers de politique de
la ville les familles même pour rejeter
ce que faisait ses 80 personnes 30 ici
50 là et à quel point ce travail que
fait ce qui est fait par les
travailleurs sociaux qui est fait par
les médiateurs il était remarquable ne
faut-il pas aller plus loin ne faut-il
pas
interroger l'efficacité mais bien sûr
que oui il faut s'interroger il faut
poursuivre ce qui marche bien peut-être
que des choses comme vous l'avez signalé
qui ont été supprimés n'auraient pas dû
être supprimé bon qui ne se trompe pas
peut-être que il faut réinterroger un
certain nombre de choses cependant en
aucun cas je souscrit avec ce que vous
avez dit et là je m'engage je sais pas
vous dire le délai mais je pense au plus
tard 15 jours parce qu'il y a le
président de la République après avoir
écouté les 400 mètres il a fait une une
conclusion sur les 8 chantiers qui
louvrent et il nous a reçu à six
ministre pour nous parler des 8
chantiers entre autres il nous a demandé
de donner des chiffres précis alors j'en
ai quelques-uns ici
3,5 milliards d'euros pour Katia 2030 et
à quel point vous l'avez dit sur la rue
il y a plus d'argent mais pas que sur la
rue et à quel point par rapport au
rapport Borlo que certains des élus hier
ont cité comme étant extrêmement
intéressant il a dit je le connais bien
peut-être je prends ma part sur le fait
que sur la forme et peut-être que j'ai
il a pas dit comme ça mais j'ai rejeté
en bloc quelque chose où il y avait des
choses intéressantes mais en tout cas
sur les montants qui étaient appelés et
sur les actions qui étaient conduites il
a demandé
à Christophe Béchu et Olivier Klein et
aux administrations afférentes de faire
remonter un bilan et ce n'est donc
encore une fois et je pense que les
montants ont été augmentés autour de 20%
ni un manque de moyens ni que cette
politique de la ville qui a été portée
par tous les gouvernements précédents
n'a pas n'a pas poursuivi n'a pas été
efficace en fait on entend quand même
beaucoup de mer hier dire que ça aurait
été bien pire voilà donc moi je
m'empresse de de vous dire que il faut
se garder de toute analyse on voit des
gens qui se sont attaqués à la
République on se voit des gens qui se
sont attaqués des jeunes de 11 ans 12
ans 13 ans 14 ans qu'est-ce qu'il y a
derrière qu'est-ce qui se laisse
entraîner est-ce que c'est eux-mêmes qui
portent cette envie de de mépriser de
d'abîmer la République en fait ils n'en
connaissent pas les valeurs donc
véritablement le dédoublement des
classes tout le monde de la saluer donc
des actions positives il y en a eu il
faut réinterroger encore une fois une
partie des actions il faut compléter le
dispositif il faut pas accuser le
gouvernement de pas avoir mis les moyens
la critique est facile la R est
difficile mais moi je ne souscris pas à
cette analyse oui oui bien sûr non non
je vais vous donner un exemple de
quelque chose qui nous coûte rien et qui
a été évoqué hier par le président
Larcher dans sa réception devant les
sénateurs et je prends ma part aussi
puisque ça personne ne l'a fait avoir
une vraie politique de peuplement dans
ces quartiers ça nous coûte rien c'est
de la volonté politique voilà il n'est
pas acceptable que dans les mêmes bars
que dans les mêmes entrées on retrouve
comme par hasard les mêmes je dirais
statistiques techniques et qui n'existe
pas officiellement mais qui sont en fait
de fait Patrick et voilà et oui
Président c'est une des chantiers que je
citais hier que sur lequel le Président
nous a demandé d'avoir
une note très rapidement monsieur le
sénateur qui est rouge
vous nous demandez d'anticiper je ne
peux que souscrire vous vous appelez un
travail sur le statut de l'élu qui est
absolument indispensable je vous redis
pas ce que je viens de dire vous serez
parmi les tous premiers sénateurs
consultés sur ce sujet
vous me dites que vous avez écrit je
suis désolé une PPL sur le statut de
l'élu est-ce que on l'a cette PPL sur
statut de l'élu oui elle vient d'être
publiée mais on l'a déjà on va
travailler dessus et on va je vais
indépendamment du travail que je conduis
avec l'AMF et je voudrais l'avoir dans
15 jours pas trop tard avant que
monsieur le sénateur quitte le Sénat un
rendez-vous d'une heure pour être sûr
que dans ce qu'on a fait on prend en
compte on s'est déjà vu on va se revoir
dans cet esprit
je suis d'accord que il a été revu qu'à
la marge vous l'avez dit je partage donc
il y a un besoin d'un travail en
profondeur
après le sénateur qui est rouge
c'était le sénateur Richard
on est d'accord
oui juste vous dire que on attend aussi
les propositions du groupe de travail
Larcher
qui est piloté par Marisa
ces deux choses différentes alors
allez-y Françoise
demain le groupe de travail sur la
décentralisation fera son rapport et il
sera présenté publiquement par le
président du Sénat donc je pense qu'il
sera utile à la réflexion générale en
particulier pour ce qui touche à la
liberté des élus locaux et leur capacité
d'agir
et puis il y a l'autre rapport qui est
la mission qui est menée actuellement
par Monsieur Darnaud et Madame Carrère
sur le rôle des mers qui va entendre
rapport dans quelques temps également
qui est encore un aspect plus précis des
choses demain également
demain vous aurez tout alors le sénateur
Richard je me souviens plus où êtes-vous
donc vous
[Musique]
vous appelez de vos vœux à ce que l'on
inventorite tout ce qu'on appelle des
irritants
vous voulez qu'on examine toutes les
situations
structurelles qui occasionnent des
irritations récurrentes vous avez raison
le zan en étain vous avez vu je me suis
énormément impliqué le côté de
Christophe Béchu très peu de temps
jusqu'au mois d'octobre et là c'est
vraiment lui qui est à la main et
aujourd'hui
on a quand même très largement il a très
largement entendu le Sénat on essaye de
trouver une position consensuelle entre
le Sénat et l'Assemblée on va laisser je
crois que c'est le 12 et le 13 juillet
que
la lecture
voilà mais avec une lecture comment on
dit une lecture
sur les gens du voyage je m'engage à
tout simplement regarder pourquoi ce
texte est bloqué à l'Assemblée nationale
et ensuite vous avez mon engagement
total vous le comprenez dans les mots
que j'ai choisi à travailler sur ces
irritants
et à veiller à ce que
ces irritants soient traités
monsieur d'Arnaud
alors Monsieur d'Arnaud
monsieur Darnaud qui considère que je
réponds pas à ces questions c'est
possible donc
probablement en tout cas c'est sincère
de votre part
[Rires]
bon par exemple vous me citez
vous me dites exemples exemple comme si
véritablement parce que vous l'avez vécu
vous trouvez ça exemplaire et ça n'était
pratiqué que là alors pas du tout les
boîtes mail
oui
oui les boîtes mails et sont partout
généralisées avec des moyens qui font
que voilà je vous parle moi il y a un an
j'étais encore mer et vous avez des
délégués du procureur qui vont faire de
la pédagogie pour que ces boîtes mails
soient connus et les moyens qui sont là
derrière font que la réponse alors il y
a des cas je redis ce que dit le garde
des sceaux mais ne nous opposons pas sur
le fait qu'il y ait des
dysfonctionnements et qu'elle ne soit
pas égayé pas tous les moyens que vous
souhaiteriez partout vous avez
probablement raison mais en attendant
aujourd'hui la volonté cette boîte mail
elle est déployer la volonté des
procureurs c'est qu'ils ne répondent
sous 24 heures moi parce que l'on m'a
amusez-vous si elle ne l'est pas
donnez-moi les lieux
alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé les amis
là
non mais c'est pas parce que c'est pas
grave que je peux pas questionner pour
savoir pourquoi je suis pas venu parce
que moi si le sénateur d'Arnaud m'invite
je viens
c'est pas grave c'est quoi pourquoi je
suis pas allé
ah ok bien allez
[Musique]
donc vous ne me demandez un exemple sur
le sujet du pouvoir réglementaire local
bon moi je vous invite à Bobo voilà si
moi je suis pas venu chez vous et c'est
trop tard mais je vous invite à Bobo
pour vous en donner plusieurs enfin
juste la composition des CCAS tout
simplement les maires peuvent les fixer
eux-mêmes voilà on peut aller plus loin
bien sûr qu'on peut aller plus loin mais
vous me demandez et ben oui ça existe
déjà mais vous me dites donnez-moi un
exemple de ce qui existe déjà c'est
parce que vous m'avez demandé alors il y
a pas de dialogue a dit monsieur le
Président parce qu'il faut aller vite
donc échangeons il y a pas de mauvaise
volonté de ma part du tout il y a une
volonté de progresser ensemble mais en
attendant il faut que vous nous écoutiez
de la même façon que je vous écoute
ensuite le sénateur Marie
là je pense avoir Marie
voilà donc je pense avoir en partie
répondu par la complexité de la violence
à laquelle on a dû faire face des
individus extrêmement jeunes des
individus coordonnés par des réseaux
sociaux des individus
[Musique]
pluriel et j'ai bien aimé ce que vous
avez dit monsieur le sénateur sur les
origines pluriels et les motivations
pluriel qui ont fait que oui des villes
comme la ville de Rouen on peut vu
ou des communes autour de la ville de
Rouen ont pas vu peu vu des policiers
parce que ils étaient concentrés sur
différents lieux et donc du coup c'est
les polices municipales qu'on fait front
et là je vais vous dire à quel point le
président ça fait aussi partie des
sujets sur lesquels il a entendu les
maires hier
cette continuité de sécurité entre la
police nationale la gendarmerie et les
policiers municipaux elle est
fondamentale et donc oui la police
municipale a fait face quand il n'y
avait pas suffisamment de police
nationale je veux quand même dire parce
que vous avez appelé de vos vœux une
compréhension sur les sanctions ça a été
3600 mais vous avez peut-être le chiffre
interpellation
346 déferments et 115 comparutions
immédiate donc
ils sont dissipés
nous aussi on les
[Musique]
avez indiqué à quel point vous avez le
sentiment de temps perdu par rapport au
rapport Borlo remettre ce chantier sur
la table j'ai répondu au président kaner
je souscris au fait que le pacte
républicain est en danger que il nous
faut véritablement à la fois travailler
sur le très court terme et sur la
protection de nos élus locaux sur la
sanction et je pense que les moyens sont
mis après il faudra les évaluer je suis
d'accord mais il nous faut travailler
aussi sur le moyen terme et il nous faut
travailler sur ces sujets comme
l'éducation bien sûr et sur
l'action sociale de proximité
le sénateur bonhomme
voilà vous avez utilisé ce terme de
cause multifactorielle c'est exactement
ça
ensuite vous avez évoqué le fait que la
communication sur le Pack Sécurité
et pas besoin de lui donner un nom et
que voilà si on doit générer un effet un
peu de rejet parce que on met un nom et
que derrière les mesures ne paraissent
peut-être pas la hauteur des attentes
donc en tout cas les actions sont
déployées sont efficaces pour ce que
j'ai pu mesurer
donc mesure judiciaire donc c'est la
filière d'urgence
c'est dans les tribunaux pris en main
par tous les procureurs c'est les
sanctions c'est les circonstances
aggravantes pour le harcèlement c'est ce
que vous allez trouver dans le plan
national de lutte sur lequel je vais
peut-être vous
réinterroger président pour être sûr que
ça reprend bien les attentes des
sénateurs et
voilà donc j'insiste sur le sujet
d'abord 20 millions peut-être je voulais
pas dire
Gérald Darmanin annoncé qu'on allait
débloquer tout de suite un budget de 20
millions pour remplacer toutes les
caméras qui avaient été détruites dans
le cadre de ses émeutes et ensuite on
travaille sur un fond de reconstruction
de toutes les dégradations en complément
de ce que les compagnies d'assurances se
vont
vont faire remonter voilà Monsieur merci
madame je dois satisfaire deux demandes
deux questions mais très très courtes
madame Dumont olympique Hermann 30
secondes
très merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre je vais juste illustrer
permettez-moi d'illustrer avec un
exemple qui est le mien une fois n'est
pas coutume j'ai été il y a quelques
mois la suite d'un amendement que
j'avais déposé
insulté
salie traîné dans la boue sur les
réseaux sociaux pendant plusieurs jours
et puis pour finir cet épisode pour
lequel on m'a dit bah restez chez vous
planquez-vous vaut mieux pas sortir de
chez vous un soi-disant humoriste sur
France Inter radio du service public
amener pendant une bonne demi-heure un
édito sur moi en me traitant
pardonnez-moi chers collègues de
fonciottes de la République entre autres
entre autres jolies compliments
et en plus comme
il ils ont envie que ça s'écoute bien
ils l'ont mis en podcast sur le site de
de France Inter bien évidemment j'ai
saisi la justice j'ai déposé plainte
alors sur l'instant vous vous sentez
pris en considération on va le procureur
m'a dit mais je vais faire diligence le
commissaire m'a dit je suis désolé je
peux pas mettre des moyens de police
parce qu'on est en soufflet s'effectif
donc on peut pas trop vous protéger
voilà
et puis audience au tribunal avait été
fixé au 23 juin là de cette 2023 et puis
ça a été repoussé c'est au 30 septembre
2024 donc en fait
l'engagement d'élus c'est pas un
engagement comme les autres on nous
demande tous les jours de l'exemplarité
et c'est bien normal dans tous les
instants de notre ville engagement des
lieux il vous prend sur votre vie privée
sur votre journée de travail sur voilà
j'estime que en retour on pourrait
exiger de l'exemplarité dans la rapidité
à traiter la sanction et à traiter la
peine
alors bien évidemment vous n'êtes pas
Madame garde des sceaux
mais c'est une chaîne qui est à prendre
en considération bon nombre d'élus de
maire demand département et pourtant je
suis pas je suis du département du Var
qui est pas un département
particulièrement sensible mais bon
nombre de maires sont l'asses de tout ça
et disent aussi bien moins 2026 je
raccroche parce que quand on a des
problèmes sur l'instant ça ça crée de
l'émotion et puis après en fait tout le
monde s'en fout moi je réclame dans le
traitement de l'exemplarité dans la
rapidité à traiter la sanction je dois
attendre plus d'un an pour savoir si
celui qui m'a traité de fonciottes de la
République va être sanctionné ou pas
merci même du monde de ce témoignage
important même que Karman même la
ministre et après en suspenda monsieur
le président
madame la ministre je vous ai entendu
d'abord je crois que dans la période oui
il faut il faut en tirer les
enseignements analysés certes avec
beaucoup d'humilité mais en tout cas on
ne peut pas satisfaire de rester en état
et pour avoir quand même discuté avec un
certain nombre d'élus je crois qu'on ne
se satisera pas simplement d'un statut
de l'élu et de 20 millions pour
remplacer les caméras parce que vous
savez quand on a plus de mairie quand il
y a plus de feu rouge qui fonctionne il
y a d'autres urgences que de remplacer
les caméras dans l'immédiateté
c'est c'est la première réponse qu'on
reçue par SMS les maires concernés par
des destructions lundi matin du ministre
excusez moi mais je pense que oui après
les jours qui viennent de se passer les
dégradations à certains de bâtiments
publics les pillages je crois qu'il y a
d'autres mesures que simplement et je ne
dis pas que ce n'est pas un problème et
qu'il faut pas remplacer les caméras
mais je crois que l'urgence de la
République lundi matin elle est ailleurs
que simplement d'annoncer ici ou là des
mesurettes voilà tout aussi fondamental
qu'elle puisse être ce même jour lundi
un sondage était publié un sondage au
doxa qui rappelle quoi qui annonce que
66 % des Français pour annoncer à se
présenter à une élection parce qu'il
craindrait pour leur sécurité et celle
de leur famille donc je crois qu'on en
est pas là simplement à se réfléchir à
quelle est la meilleure proposition de
loi du moment on en est à se dire que
dans trois ans nous pourrions avoir dans
un certain nombre de communes plus de
candidats et nous l'avons déjà vu parce
qu'en 2020 le nombre de communes où il
n'y avait plus qu'une seule liste là
wawei n'avait plusieurs et donc comment
est-ce que l'on garantit effectivement à
ce que en 2026 les communes puissent
être pourvu en nombre d'élus sauf à se
dire qu'il y aurait trop de communes et
qu'on pourrait les voir disparaître et y
compris dans le respect d'un pluralisme
qui redonne du pouvoir aux élus locaux
pour refaire de la politique et refaire
vivre de la démocratie aller champ
communale merci un ami
merci monsieur le Président donc vous
appelez de vous et madame la sénatrice
de l'exemplarité vous avez tout à fait
raison donc je souscris à votre
grande déception je vous dis deux choses
d'abord les moyens de la justice et si
vous voulez bien les voter
il y a une loi de programmation pour la
justice qui est en cours ou les avait
déjà voté d'ailleurs mais ça va ça va
revenir ça va nous revenir c'est pas
entièrement la CMP les c'est passé à
l'Assemblée aussi
[Musique]
au début puis derrière il vous faut
attendre 2024 donc je l'entends mais
attention si vous voulez à ces
expressions de colère que je peux avoir
moi-même mais qui font que finalement on
croit plus dans notre République parce
que il y a des dysfonctionnements comme
celui que vous pointez
je suis d'accord ensuite madame
cukkermann vous et je le respecte
totalement vous dites que ce n'était pas
ni le moment ni la mesure d'annoncer le
remplacement des caméras mais moi je
l'ai dit à monsieur le Président
cannaire je respecte tout à fait et vous
seriez en situation de gouvernance vous
feriez autre chose moi je suis là pour
vous écouter pour entendre ce qu'il
aurait fallu dire mais en tout cas moi
je vous dis que je suis solidaire du
ministre de l'Intérieur et je suis ravi
qu'il ait pu et d'ailleurs c'est que
madame la présidente de région
Île-de-France a dit mais moi je
souscrirai tout de suite quand on est
allé dimanche la première
urgence c'est de remplacer ce qui va
nous permettre tout simplement
de cet exemplarité que vous appelez de
vos vœux c'est-à-dire
la capacité à pouvoir des donner des
éléments à la justice donc bien sûr que
c'est prendre soin on est allé au chevet
des mers moi j'ai eu plusieurs fois et
vu la mère de Pontoise j'ai vu le maire
de les roses donc l'humain est des
équipes municipales pas seulement du
maire de toutes les équipes donc
l'humain il est fondamental je pense
qu'il est au cœur de ce que Gérald
Darmanin Christoph même faisons je pense
qu'il est au cœur de ce que font les
préfets mais aussi
le remplacement des caméras qui peut se
faire assez vite rapidement et était une
priorité et vous me dites le statut de
l'élu je m'attaque à un sujet qui est un
peu un sujet qui a tourné en rond et
vous me dites ça changera pas tout mais
vous allez totalement raison mais à
aucun moment j'ai dit avec vous allez
voir ce que vous allez voir avec le
statut de l'élu notre République
l'autorité tout ça ça va très bien
fonctionner donc le statut de l'élu
c'est nécessaire mais évidemment pas
suffisant les 20 millions d'euros de
remplacement des carrés Mira c'est
nécessaire mais évidemment pas suffisant
et puis pardonner mon mon voilà moi je
vois le vert à moitié plein plutôt qu'à
moitié vide donc quand vous me dites que
66% des Français aujourd'hui
se posent des questions et que vous
craignez à juste titre que on manque de
candidats dans certaines communes je
travaille avec la sénatrice Gatel sur
les communes nouvelles parce que je
pense que il faut qu'on soit encore plus
en accompagnement pour essayer de faire
en sorte que effectivement ce que
de faire ensemble et bien on fasse
ensemble mais en attendant moi je ne
suis pas inquiète parce que je vois des
toutes petites communes dans lesquelles
je vois des mers qui ont démissionné qui
finalement neuro démissionnent pas parce
que ils vont à l'opposition arriver et
l'être humain est ainsi fait que je
pense que même dans les petites communes
malheureusement je vois des gens émerger
avec une envie de gouverner la commune
de s'opposer à ce qui a été fait par le
passé mais en tout cas cette envie de de
d'être mère même si elle est il faut
prendre en compte ce sondage il faut
conduire une réflexion mais moi je pense
que en 2027 on n'aura pas beaucoup plus
de communes sans candidats qu'on en a eu
on en aura plus mais pas beaucoup plus
c'est pas un sujet majeur d'inquiétude
pour moi aujourd'hui et j'espère que je
ne me trompe pas mais en tout cas j'ai
compris l'appel à vigilance que vous
avez formulé madame la sénatrice
merci Madame la Ministre on va conclure
la Réunion mais je peux pas m'empêcher
de ne pas répondre aux présidents sur la
notion de peuplement
ça fait très longtemps que je considère
j'ai été maire que la question d'une
langue sociale n'est pas un problème
nous avons besoin de logements sociaux
il y a aucun doute mais que la question
de fond c'est notre capacité
effectivement à en gérer le peuplement à
ne pas rajouter de la misère sur la
misère et si ça veut dire si on peut
avoir l'unanimité en tous les cas large
rassemblement sur cette idée là on sera
en capacité d'avancer utilement et je
pense que c'est bien nécessaire et ça
fait longtemps que ce sujet sur la table
ça fait longtemps qu'il est aussi
l'objet de polémique
dont il faut se sortir mais c'est une
des pistes à mon avis voir la piste
majeure à mettre en place rapidement
parce qu'elle sera à leur un effet utile
et également rapidement merci Madame la
Ministre merci à tous on se revoit à 11h
merci président